I'm here to meet one of our Sam's most
celebrated chefs at old lacquer
he runs two restaurants and he's agreed
to show me one of his classic fish
curries how are you I'm fine good to see
good Basile we start for pissing piss
increasing oh yeah you like using I love
fishing yeah because people of our songs
we like fish yeah that's how atolls
cooking is better than his English you
ready guy ready ready do you want wait
for me yeah brakes don't work on line
150,000 Islanders live here and they
survived almost entirely on a diet of
fish and all that comes from these
freshwater ponds 99% of the village live
on fish yes yes first Wow
Jesus Christ that boats nothing to put
up with a fat bastard like me I tell you
[Laughter]
[ __ ] start wasn't it
see I knew wouldn't take fifties sorry
guys we apologize for me you're a lot
like than I am these guys are these
flimsy boats can't take a culinary
heavyweight like me so on to plan B well
we've got some more fish from the market
we've bought some fish and now a tours
gonna cook dengue a traditional Assamese
fish curry that has a truly unique
flavor what's that you did elephant
happily and what do they taste like
apples it's alleged killer so uh yeah
it's good acidic yeah it's this tropical
fruit that gives dengue its signature
sour flavor which will add a bite to the
earthy taste of a freshwater fish so
where's the recipe from everywhere are
some people use this type of fish okay
green chili very good but no spices no
no only chili dues uh-huh yeah why is
that I was silly the sauce special yeah
sorry not his Italy parodies of silly
rosewood shilling in order that is a
hottie silly reward
yes so yep garlic what have you got in
there what you put in
[Music]
and is that you done then yeah my poor
my good is feeling Yoko is finished
sharing in a hurry
you're like my traditional awesomest
food that Co is delicious and you've
managed to make it with no spices yeah
so I totally understand where you're
coming from
it's been really good thank you now just
before we go I want you just say one
thing for me fishing fishing snake snack
not miss another good
snake snake on my trip I've realized
that the curry we know and love in the
UK is really a narrow selection of the
amazing dishes India has to offer
[Music]